donnant mon combat il va lui va bien
hier soir les fans cg c'est à dire
attends and death is here coup de gueule
non non à quoi s'est connu d'ennuis vous
connaissent pas dans le milieu alors je
voudrais lequel vous parler quelques
mois on est quoi le mois de juin il y
avait une deadline hier ou ce soir qui
était décalée à leysin plus simple on a
fait ce qu'on appelle une compte à key
west mon expert-comptable et guay mon
expert comptable commissaire aux comptes
est gay j'embrasse jean-philippe donc il
est venu chez moi oui il s'occupe du
tout ils déclarent des trucs c'est
compliqué des droits d'auteur des
machins des cartoons à peu près une
heure le bilan actif ou passif
[Rires]
c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois on fait ça
derrière arides comme chacun ont des
rites des machins religieux ou pas nous
on fait ça et après la compta on fait
l'amour non avec ton copain scène qu'ont
tagué et surtout 6 david jaffe tafer
déclaré un peu moins d'impôts il à
réussir des trucs et tout ça alors on
fait doublement alors ouais mais c'est
connu chez les gays mais c'est sûr que
si tu sais pas c'est que t'es pas c'est
quand tu trouves des comptes année
comptable guéi est une association quoi
comment tu fus n'avons ni les
installations effectivement amicales
1 mais par exemple vous avez déjà des
terres et vodafone a bien sûr bah oui à
dommage on a pu s'en occuper
[Rires]
ce que lui jusqu'à du repreneur c'est
bizarre en tout cas d'après ce qu'on m'a
dit il paraît que dans votre lit plat
pas de majoration géraldine manic merci
c'est vrai avec un de vos amis je sais
qu'à fait il m'a envoyé la folie
tellement fusionnel avec vous aime
tellement
ouais il a le même projet et délires
capillaires mais il l'a fait hier c'est
benoît p en fait il m'a envoyé une photo
il a été chez le coiffeur et il m'a dit
je fais la même chose que toi
son modèle il a assumé vous copier c'est
moi il m'a dit je vais comme cyril un
viseur son modèle cela ébranle ah ouais
mais alors je vous dirais moi c'est mon
modèle tennistiquement ben voila voila
et ya trouvé vous adore ouais ouais
c'est bon ça donc voilà je t'embrasse
très fort montbenoit imitée jamais
égalée par les fouad habash droit de
vous offrir aux gens essaient de vous
imiter mais personne n'arrive à vous
égalez non demain on me demande si
confiant sa photo la photo c'est très
vrai les bandas on avance